[Music]
through
film and media we can learn about
empathy empathy is something we really
need right now
story and art has the power to change
things in the world and make the world a
better place
it's giving people a relief from their
lives
for a couple of hours i think it's up to
filmmakers to do
what's right using their influence for
the greater good
if i have seen my film what i'm really
looking for
is generic universal language anyone
could watch this film
and put themselves in our character's
shoes and i think that's beautiful
we are doing this film to bring change
this kind of
crime should never happen again i want
people to
look critically how that these stories
are still going on
really looking introspectively and
thinking what is wrong with that
i want that the audience take away how
they affect the
environment and nature with a cup of
coffee
what is your role in the world to what
extent you have impact and how can you
do better
i want them to ask who was the real
culprit
how i want to raise awareness i think
what's
so important to me is to expose the
world to south african stories to
south african talent it would be
important for me
for people to just leave with an
appreciation for these kids who are far
more resilient
and smarter and have a very real sense
of what life is
in these times filmmaking helps us
heal i don't think filmmaking is
important i think
it's essential for our lives
welcome everyone i'm david rubin
president of the academy of motion
picture arts and sciences
it's my honor to introduce the first
ever virtual student academy awards
although i'm hopeful as we all are that
this will also be the last
virtual student academy awards just as
inflection points like the cold war and
911
shape the perspective of past
generations of filmmakers
from stanley kramer to catherine bigelow
2020 a year like no other will no doubt
forever influence what your generation
sees through the camera lens
and judging by this year's nearly 1500
submissions received from 328 schools
from albania to vietnam what a promising
generation you are
my thanks go to the more than 750
academy members
who volunteered their time to judge
entries in seven categories
and had the challenging responsibility
of selecting this year's gold
silver and bronze winners and now i'm
pleased to introduce someone whose
career trajectory
from mexico city to hollywood is an
inspiring example of carving one's own
path
recently he starred in an
executive-produced dora and the lost
city of gold
please welcome the host of this year's
student academy awards
actor director and producer eugenio
terbes
thank you david hello everyone
even though i'm the one on your screen
right now
this night is for the people who deserve
the credit you
the nominees and recipients of this
year's awards
who earned the applause that we're
sending across the internet to you
bravo you know over time
hollywood has become more inclusive more
open
more accepting but we still have a ways
to go
to make it in hollywood is not easy but
however at its best
our industry can be that shining example
that there's room at the table for
everyone this year we couldn't be on a
stage
but in previous years we couldn't or
wouldn't do
what just happened a week ago we invited
this year's
students to be part of a zoom interview
and asked them
how it felt to be a finalist and then
listen
and then we surprised them by beaming in
legends from their fields who then
revealed the real news to each winner
so let's get to what really matters the
spectacular artists
who are all winners in tonight's first
category
animation and international animation
every year
the winners in this field find
mesmerizing new ways to transform
pen and ink into pixels and plasma
screens
and your new generation promises to push
us towards farther frontiers
this year's domestic animation winners
had the joy of being given the big news
by an oscar-winning disney legend and
animation director
of the soon to be released over the moon
glenn king and it's a real pleasure to
introduce you to
glenn keane wow
oh my god hi such an honor to meet you
sorry you're you're like my hero
thank you kate daniela christie maya
congratulations you have won the bronze
medal for
your beautiful beautiful film hamsa
thank you
thank you so much such an honor to me
honestly i'm fighting back tears right
now this is
amazing our story is about a little girl
her mother tells her to fear the other
or the unknown
she soon learns that actually we're all
the same
and that there's no reason to fear each
other i feel like
anyone can watch this film and put
themselves in
our character's shoes i thought that it
was like a very meaningful story
where like we can change a new
generation's mindset
i think it's really important to show
different cultures on screen
us as a team we have so many countries
that we represent
it just proves to you that we can go
past what we look like
i just want to thank first and foremost
my thesis partners
i also really want to thank my family
and friends
who knew that i could do it more than i
even knew i would love to thank my
thesis advisors
harry darrington elizabeth kuaharero
eric kuna
and sva for supporting us through our
journey and difficulties
we definitely could not have done it on
our own
i would just like to thank my family i
love you guys so much
all my friends from back home thank you
again to the academy this is honestly
like
so amazing so thank you
an honor to tell you you have won the
silver
medal award for beautiful beautiful film
mind your manners thank you so much it's
amazing to hear it from you
i wish i could give you a hug right
alcohol virtual hug
[Music]
our film is about an arrogant man that
is transformed into a mime
and then he has to grow to be a better
person to be free from
the story was important to us because we
wanted to tell like a lesson
about anger and controlling that anger
and how you want to be treated
and how you treat others i hope this
story resonates with other people
because
it's about the golden rule and to show
that even if someone
at one point is hateful and angry that
they can grow and to
understand each other our film mime your
manners won a student academy award
oh my goodness what yeah
i want to thank my mom and dad my
brother and sister
and the rest of my family for being so
loving and supportive
i'd like to thank my older brother
keaton my parents and my family
and last but not least my significant
other rebecca
your film servo is absolutely beautiful
you have won the gold for the student
academy award
thank you so much there you go there you
go go ahead and take it
my film is about a
young girl grappling with an abusive
violent relationship
and also comparing that relationship to
deer and predator prey relationships in
the environment
what i want people to take away is
understanding of
the difficult situations that are
portrayed and feelings of empathy for a
lot of the characters that maybe
wouldn't normally have empathy for i
always feel like
the best way to express something for me
is just visuals and drawings and images
even if it's images that don't really
mean anything
else
i'd like to thank the academy for giving
me such a wonderful opportunity and
giving me this amazing award i feel
truly humbled
and honored to be one of the recipients
this year i'd encourage people to share
themselves and share their work and
share each other's work and
connect to it and talk about it stay
passionate and driven
as long as you have a goal and you're
passionate about it you can do anything
thank you to the student academy awards
for this amazing opportunity
and hopefully we'll see you later
congratulations to our animation winners
also
our international animation winner was
surprised by the
amazingly talented japanese artist and
filmmaker
who most recently gave us the
mesmerizing experimental film
leaking life
your film won the gold medal in the
international animation category
no no no way no this is not no no no no
no this is a joke right oh my god beauty
won this year's student academy award
oh that's cool congratulations
nice thank you very much
[Music]
my film is about an ironic journey
through a breathtaking underwater world
where nature
and plastic becomes one the story is
important to me
because nature gives me so much it's so
important to keep nature
alive i want the audience to take away
some sensibility about cleanly used
plastic
hopefully changed their mind a little
bit more during this production i wasn't
like in a tunnel
reaching this unreachable oscar
aces somewhere it's like landing on the
moon or something dear academy
thank you so much for choosing the
beauty as a winner i want to
thank also my entire team for supporting
me on this crazy journey
and i'm also want to thank the entire
film academy bob burton back and the
institute of animation
and last but not least i'm gonna thank
my wife and my kids to give me strengths
and hope to wrap it all together thank
you so much
bye-bye
[Music]
congratulations to our animation winners
i love animation i really love animation
growing up
i learned a lot from the great animated
films
although until i was 12 i thought all
mice had four fingers
and now it's time for our next award
categories
alfred hitchcock said in feature films
the director is god in documentary films
god is the director in the hands of this
year's winners
conscience and conviction work together
to make a world of
complexity and conflict just a little
clearer
and and that's why it was so appropriate
that they received their good news from
a groundbreaking
documentarian who most recently reminded
us of the power of getting into
good trouble yeah the film exploring the
life and legacy
of john lewis i'm talking about
missionary producer
director and writer don potter
i get the honor of telling you that you
have won a medal
you are the bronze medalist in
documentary
in this year's student academy awards
congratulations so much
i didn't expect that
[Music]
lania is a french ocean activist
i fold her all over the world trying to
protect
sea turtles from being punched and waves
from being hunted
[Music]
her story shows everything is possible
as long as you follow your ethics and
your passion
making way from the middle we need
to savor this moment
i would like people to really question
what is my relationship to the ocean
to what extent the way i eat can have an
impact
i am touched and so appreciative that
the academy
is helping your light to shine on an
environmental issue
to raise awareness special thanks to my
family and my parents
to new york university to my relatable
collaborators
to my co-workers and supervisors from
great disparity
death medal is also recognition for
lamya established education
thank you for her thank you
i have the honor of telling you that you
are a silver medal
winner in documentary film for the
academy of motion pictures
are you serious mysterious
my film the dope years is about latasha
harland
who was shot and killed right before the
los angeles uprising
in 1991. black in a country
where coming of age is coming up far too
short
each flower before me represents those
black and brown children whose stories
were cut short due to gun violence and
racial profiling
as a result of playing music too loud
for asking for directions
and in latasha harlan's case for buying
orange juice at the age of 15.
these stories are still going on i think
as filmmakers we should always strive
to not be afraid of thinking critically
and asking questions
i am a christian there is this verse
that says write it out and make it plain
one of my goals that i had written out
before i went to usc
was to win the student academy award
i just recently erased it from the
window
that was an incredible feeling
to my producers minnie wet andreas
and marquise and my ride or die 547 team
fatima ika kevin jalis derek august and
lawford to my mom and dad
you mean the world to me this award is
dedicated to activist denise harland's
who never
remain silent thank you to ebony and
naomi for sharing your
lives with me thank you to the usc
school of cinematic arts for seeing the
promise in the story
and thank you to the academy for this
honor and recognition
this is for latasha i have the honor of
telling you
you are the gold medal winner in
documentary this year
[Music]
really congratulations
my film is about a chinese student
shinji who was
beaten to death five years ago near the
ufc
campus and our main subject
rose thai is trying to fight for his
justice
we are doing this film to bring change
this kind of
crime should never happen again
it's very hard to remain objective
because i can
feel so much pain with experienced
parents and
everyone in the story that's also why i
call it unfinished lives because i feel
like for
everyone their lives is just unfinished
i feel like the future of films is in
fantastic hands with artists like you
so thank you i'm crying
okay uh so i have another news to
announce to all of you
we are the winner and we won the gold
medal
in the documentary category
we did this film to owner sharon's life
and i'm very glad that
people care about the story and we got
recognized by the academy
i want to thank syria's parents and rose
and joao and all the subjects we
interviewed
not only because they supported the film
but also what they did
for the case they made the story happen
i also want to thank my crew and my
mentor amanda
they are the best crew and vendor i can
ever ask for
i also want to thank my parents thank
you for telling me that
my life is unlimited i love you all
how are you i'm good how are you it is
my honor to tell you that you've won the
gold medal
why you've won the gold medal
in international documentary oh my god
my heart is beating so fast right now
first of all i would like to thank the
for even letting us
tell her story for opening up to us
my film is about that she is an adult
now
but it's about her story a childhood
being abused by her own father
[Music]
because
the film is about her taking back the
power of her own life
not just the story about experiencing
trauma
and being a victim but the power that
you have within yourself to actually
choose not to be a victim to choose to
stand up
i wanted to shine a light on the subject
i needed to show the strength
of panther as strong as a woman i've
ever met
her story can help a lot of people in a
field or in a subject
that people don't actually talk about
i'm kind of falling in love with
documentary because you're telling
stories of real people and no matter who
you meet on the street or
sit next to you on the bus everyone has
a story
i'm gonna say a sentence that i never
thought that i would say
thank you to the academy bye
if documentary films rebuild the world
as it is
our next category alternative
experimental
invites us into a world as only the
filmmaker can see it
from warhol to bunuel to fassbender and
ackermann
they they dare to make us uncomfortable
if jung luis taught us the importance of
good trouble
then this year's alternative and
experimental films
share with us that the good kind of
uncomfortable
shunsaku hayashi has said that
alternative work is
is like traveling alone somewhere
strange to get lost
disoriented and to explore new meanings
so i know the winner was thrilled when
shunsako himself
was kind enough to present their medals
in this category
your film won the gold medal in the
alternative
experimental category congratulations is
this a joke or is it real
you're not a student academy award
winner oh my god
our film won the gold award at the
student academy oscars
so you guys are all academy award
winners
you guys are great i'm speechless
[Music]
when i work i truly and fully led
by my imagination and intuition
simulacra is a concept mainly about the
connections between reality
society and symbolism and also about
duality
it's important for the whole world
in 2020 because there are a lot of
surreal things
happening i really want to find a way to
convey this alternative modes of star
timing
my film is motion captures 3d scans 3d
motion graphics
installations even contemporary theater
i really want to say big thank you to my
mom and my dad and
having their always been super
supportive i really want to say big
thank you to all my crew
my friends my colleagues especially
faculty from unc
i'd like to thank the academy for
bestowing this tremendous honor on our
film simulacra
thank you to the student academy awards
for the award
thanks so much
the student academy awards are the best
recognition
you can expect if you are a student
filmmaker
it's the thing that everybody wants to
win it's the oscars of
students
[Music]
i don't know i keep hearing the word
medalist so i guess it looks like a
medal
is it like a stick figure with its arms
out and maybe like wings
i don't know how to describe it it's
like a box
wish the the student academy award would
be a small version of the real oscar
like a little student with glasses on it
and a bad haircut
making this this this pose don't have
money and
something like that will be will be
really great
the biggest lesson oh my god too many
lessons it was exhausting
don't animate when you're sick
just don't do it one of the most
important things that i learned
is to trust your gut you know what's
best it's your story
nobody knows it like you do just do it
you're gonna fail but when you fail you
grow
that i was going to win a student
academy award because
maybe it was going to give me more
confidence in what i was doing
i wish i knew that the first cut of the
film
was going to be one hour long perhaps i
could have you know
written a few more scenes and i would
have made a feature out of it
if you fly a drone very close to a river
it will get sucked down and you will
lose it
and it will cost a lot of money
i recently watched stanley kubrick's
eyes white shot
there was a guy who had a totally
different idea of how to wear masks
it was kubrick who said a narrative film
should be
more like music than like fiction
it should be a progression of moods and
feelings
the theme what's behind emotion all that
comes later
this year's student winners take us
inside the moods and feelings of
characters
that command our attention and capture
our affection
and like the best conductors they lead
the orchestra to a crescendo
and leave us on the edge of our seats
waiting for resolution
we are hooked let's first hear from our
international narrative winners and
let's
relive the big reveal as they learned
they were winners
receiving the news from the acclaimed
writer and director of
last year's independent spirit award
winning
the farewell lulu wang
you are a student academy award winner
your film was one the bronze medal
in the international narrative category
whoa thank you so much i wasn't
expecting
this to be like uh the results right now
like my heart is like uh
pounding like
[Music]
when they told me my roommate which is
also my best friend was
like right next to the door i wanted to
open it and just like
hug her hug someone because you know
you're just like in zoom and you want to
be with people you want to
share the things
[Music]
[Applause]
the name of my movie is i was still
there when you left me
[Music]
while her block is burning at seven
years old girl is consumed with guilt
thinking she started the fire of her
building
i want my audience to feel is empathy
for sure
i want them to ask who was the real
culprit of the fire
it's obvious that it's not the little
girl's fault and i guess
from what you see in the movie you can
find answers
i'm this girl from paris studying in
belgium
winning an academy award it's so hard to
process but i think it's a beautiful way
to welcome
our generation into the film industry
and i hope it's gonna inspire girls
around me to believe that they can
achieve
whatever they want
[Music]
you are a student academy award winner
your film has won the silver medal in
the international narrative category
no way wow this is
this is a lot to process right now i
mean this is a great surprise
well this is it's big and i just can't
wait to
tell my sisters and my parents and my
teammates you know
it's a lot
i studied film directing at centro de
capacitacion cinematographica
my film is called crescendo
crescendo tells the story of a young
violinist who
really really wants her teacher to
accept her into his prestigious string
quartet
but in the process she learns that she
really needs to stay away from
anyone who expects her to do anything
other than playing music
we like to think of crescendo as a story
of empowerment in the face of abuse we
wanted to be part of that conversation
that was long overdue i'm really happy
to say that
making crescendo was a delight for me
and
my whole team actually we are very much
in love with each other you know
my team was really there for me and was
really there for the project
i would really like to thank my parents
and my sisters
of course i'd like to thank the cast and
the crew
last but not least i'd like to thank the
academy for this huge recognition
the whole team is excited about it
you've won a student academy award
your film has won the gold medal
in the international narrative category
very well deserved and congratulations
well uh i need some second to process
this
now if i'm gonna tell my team that this
happened in my school they're going to
all freak out
[Music]
i'm german gulp and i'm from estonia
from tallinn
and i study in baltic film media school
and we did the film my dear corpses or
in estonian
mukhalik labor basically talking about
a young man who is desperate to get his
home back for his
mother and he will start to work as a
corpse transporter
[Music]
[Applause]
i worked myself as a course transporter
so i know this work
and this film is not autobiographical or
some biopic in a sense
i just had some experience and i thought
that what
happened if i'm gonna push it a little
bit further
and tell something important that i
understand personally
it's a rite of passage i try to give
people opportunity to say that
we are not immortal we have to remember
that
we have to remember what is human
what makes us human that's the most
important thing
i would like to recognize for my win but
i wouldn't say my win because a whole
lot of people
did this and they were so delegated to
the project and
that made a whole difference if it's
done from the heart
then it's done the best way on this
project worked
over 90 people for you all
thank you again elanco phil mcquinst
and now our final award of the evening
the 2020
student academy awards for domestic
narrative
just imagine how thrilling it was for
them to have their sum
interrupted by a living legend not just
of the academy
but also of the student academy listen
in 1983
the academy bestowed a student award on
a 26 year old for his master's thesis
well 37 years later he's still breaking
new grounds with
the five bloods we were honored
that the inemitable filmmaker and oscar
winner
spike lee joined us to pass the creative
torch
basically i'm on this call hello
hello talia how are you i'm good how are
you
and then they asked me you know what it
feels like being a finalist it's always
a very
romantic idea to be recognized by the
academy and they say to me we have a
surprise for you
i've invited a special guest to join us
and then
spike lee popped up hey
hi spike is this happening
it's not just like magic it's me
i'm like what it's it's such an honor to
meet you spike like i
ramel it's mine i'm here to tell you
you won the bronze award
[Music]
oh
my name is romel villa i went to the
university of southern california and my
film
is sweet potatoes my film is
a historical film about luis miramontes
the mexican scientist who synthesized
the birth control pill
the story basically focuses on the
religious personal
and socioeconomical consequences of his
invention
it definitely feels great is a huge
honor
to to have this win there have been many
times where
i didn't believe i was talented there
are a lot of i think
confident struggles that filmmakers go
through so getting this
win it's it means i think it means
everything
first of all i would like to thank god
for the blessings and challenges that
life has given to me
uh thank you so much to my family to my
partner and to my friends for believing
in me especially when i don't believe in
myself
this film was made with the heart and
soul of a lot of minorities
who put their passion into filmmaking
congratulations you've won
the silva award
oh my god no i got a call yesterday and
i found out that i won the student
academy award
wow i'm kurish
dupe from new york university grad film
program
and my film is called bitu
and it's hard it's an examination of a
very close friendship between two girls
i put in a lot of my personal
experiences going to school in india
in there as well i'm it's inspired a lot
by my own relationship with authority
a lot of my work stems from the idea of
individuality and the course that comes
with it
especially in like traditional societies
winning a student academy award means
everything really at this point in my
career
i think the validation is very important
romantically any filmmaker anywhere in
the world would
love to be recognized by the academy it
kind of puts a lot of
life and energy into what you really
need to keep going
i'd like to thank my amazing strong
wonderfully strange family back home in
india who are responsible for me being
here today
i'd never made a film before going to
the nyu grad film program and i learned
it all from my friends
so i'd like to thank each and every
person on the team of bittu your work
has transformed the movie
congratulations thank you so much
you've won the gold
gold is the top prize
spike lee told me that we
got gold that um
that's what you
it's a story that a lot of south
africans
can relate to from different
perspectives
within the film and i think it's
important for
south africans to be able to see
themselves but also to see
the other people who they have
relationships with and see their
perspectives
thank you so much to the academy you
made the dreams of
a little eight-year-old girl from south
africa come true
just to be nominated is phenomenal where
am i coming
um thank you nyu for championing
this film my incredible producing team
my incredible cast i feel like the film
guards
put you on this earth to be this far
i'm standing here as a really proud
south african because i know that this
is
a validation to us all that our stories
have a place
to be told and we can tell them
thank you
[Music]
under one hour huh maybe they should
have me host the oscars
well what a night this has been watching
the look of pure joy on the faces of our
winners
as the legends they look up to share the
incredible news that
so much hard work has paid off it's
it's you know it's the look of
determination rewarded
and congratulations delivered by the
very best in the field
to the best yet to come all those late
nights
so many dreams and so much daring and so
much hope
reaffirmed and renewed about the promise
and potential that stretches
out still ahead admittedly
2020 has given us all reason to drink
right but tonight tonight has given us
reason
to lift the glass and raise a toast
to the time when we can all be together
again in person
to big dreams and to a hopeful tomorrow
cheers
this is water come on